she was attractive love drugs a lot of
drugs was she killed and did she
overdosed that's overdose for sure
sucking dick don't coke poor thing
gorgeous though so as you're back from
the day no one's really that curvy no
Mae West
you ever seen Mae West no Bree I'm a
West for a second brother Emil Monroe
don't bro but when you're at it while
you're at it after that bring up Rita
Hayworth like you to bring up I'd also
like you to bring up Sofia Iran Mae West
with the original she was the original
sex queen and this is what she looked
like she'd be I come up and see me
sometime big boy you know that [ __ ] she
would say yo you get your ass out of my
face track this bus but two men back
then she was all Kansas sex a come up
and see me sometime
nope not happening I'm shoot if there
was 15 of her in a brothel to pull the
chin and I'm 80 she's not attractive how
about I have these guys and I don't know
the statistic you might be a little kid
up chin but even David Spade said this
his house got broken into and they said
most time it's from a lot of times from
the people working on your house whether
you you're doing a new deck the lawn
service the up the landscape whatever it
is there's connections through there
there so years ago my house got broke
into from sources that lead to that that
are from the landscaping I don't know
what exec it is so have these guys
working on my house right now
dude supposed to be at 8 o'clock no one
shows up and they're in the middle of
this project it's a disaster they have
to finish this because I can't leave the
front of my house how it finishes I know
where is he doesn't show up calling guys
text like dude I have to get this done
my kid can't work out we gotta go out
the side like it's a disaster
please we got to figure this out then
finally the three other workers come Leo
and he got picked up for grand theft the
hollow last night what the [ __ ] man and
this guy was all up literally sitting in
my car we time out cars ahh
that's a nice car here so yeah I know
yeah so what can you do first get strong
oh yeah they do
oh yeah oh they do I've seen the movie
[ __ ] deal but I feel like those cars
those cars are so easy to see in spot
that you can't really nice piece of
change but you can be like oh my car was
stalling just look for the only Porsche
like that
yeah but they can take you to who knows
where and chop it up or so would they
chop that up though they I mean that
that'd be it's hard teaches that alight
yeah oh yeah I feel like that's too hard
to hide now because by the time I who
knows but it is a bomber man Wow
crazy right people who live nearby
that's the start oh yeah I know just
like what the [ __ ] I don't know what you
do cuz you need those security and dog
me too dogs me too now yeah guns I had
cameras and I said hey let the guy know
you seem like a good dude but just let
him know literally everything guys do is
recorded and I've guns in sight like
it's just I don't know if he's thinking
about coming this way whatever it is but
I need that's done so you guys finishes
that this we're going separate ways I'm
gonna pay you but just know everything
you guys do I see everything's recorded
I have security dogs at [ __ ] guns
yeah just let me know that for me yeah
and these guys were great too like dude
we can we do that's not our style what's
going on there we have for sure stuff
that's a job for some people men some
people that just could it just a bummer
I mean the guy's been like you said he's
doing this projects he's been the first
know kind of what kind of sentence that
probably depends on how many you know
how many offenses you so do you have any
desire to see this movie which agent
movie not really really I heard it see
people love it I don't know what it's
about
I'm gonna watch it but I'll probably you
know I'll see on demand its rear I go
the movies I'm supporting if you watch
on thaw yeah and then I can pay for be
off Sealand event yeah I want to see it
on demand I will illegally stream it
from an Asian site which is just as good
my wife was on Safari and they were in
Kenya and apparently the Chinese
he's a bus of Chinese oh were purposely
separating a baby gazelle for her mom
prepaid ashita from the mother cheetah
eat it
nope they were just trying to look at
the cheetah and keep the baby and so
they separate the mama guides got very
mad and apparently there was somebody in
the group of international people that
my wife was either with or close to that
she didn't know who screamed get your
Chinese asses the [ __ ] away from that
cheetah it was a very kind of tense they
all looked over I said I'm talking to
you I think he was from Norway you just
panicked I was trying to get the
reaction out of them it's not really
it's kind of not really a very kind of
you trying to asses had to get your
American asses out of here
I'm not offensive
get your Chinese asses and they didn't
move of course did they're lucky the
[ __ ] cheated it ripped their fate and
they they shot the baby cheetah all and
I mean there was nothing left
they and dust and they'd the cheetah
with chopsticks yeah that's I did not
corroborate that story no all right
spitballing ideas here breasts spittin
Paul was a guy who did literally a guy I
met him one time and he goes Sara PEC
deck sir PEC deck and just Jim you know
I can get it I can't find a solid PEC
deck who's that guy knew you a guy you
know great guy had come over to be an
actor for a while it didn't work out you
know really a nice guy and I wasn't
there but his friends said that al got
arrested I go having us he got pulled
over with his buddy
and there was a girl with him right so
he wanted empresa gorgeous I got this
don't worry about it cop La Casa [ __ ]
around the button-down cop shows up in
the sirdar's license to me goes like
this you guys yeah not a problem
here's my driver's license that's 100 if
it comes back it doesn't it doesn't come
back it doesn't come back with the
license the tacos
excuse me sir because it doesn't come
back it doesn't come back conquers is
this a bribe sir and he goes bribe to
donation doesn't work yeah the car
service work does collect quiet doesn't
walk around
there's only that way at all yeah it is
there anything we're swinging it shot
shot down like that God ever my god ever
one time I got pulled when I was I was
going in and out trying to meet Todd
Phillips for uh I was late with my wife
and I was we were trying to get to have
dinner with Todd Phelps I was late
way to go be yeah of course right as
usual and I'm like fool and cop it takes
an off-duty cop and he goes hey he goes
what are you doing
I've been watching you do this insane
stuff what are you doing I go I know I'm
really sorry I'm going to meet somebody
I can't be late he goes okay but I'm a
police officer and I just saw you make
about 20 different violations I go I did
I did I'm that panicked and he goes all
right well do me a favor if I see do it
again I'm gonna pull you over and I'm
off duty right now and I'm gonna give
you the ticket of your life I'm like I'm
sorry and he goes yeah and he goes
alright I go hey dude listen can I get
any you like comedy you like stand-up
comedy I go come to my show I'll I'll
give you any time you want and he goes
no I can't do that I can't tackle bro
what just what's your name tell me your
name I'll write it down here's my number
he goes I can't it would be a it would
be against my via my principles I was
like ah [ __ ] I never mind you know doing
whatever I could yeah you try to help it
have you ever had like you other words I
mean shot down or I'll get to that like
your way especially when I singular
slang the girls DMS are you talking you
take your shot and she's like what what
you doing right now you know I mean
that's so embarrassing you misread
signalled like in the day and you
thought she was oh my yeah yeah we have
a prong construct what are you thinking
no when I said you want to see my [ __ ]
that's autocorrect you wanna see my prop
my pride props cuz I'm an actor I didn't
get a cop I didn't mean [ __ ] I met my
unsheath dog oh no I'm sorry
Autocar guts run when I say [ __ ] I meant
my giant dick I meant I have no interest
in you as a person I just want to bang
you cuz you have no interest in the
skills you possess no super I may not go
out to dinner and pretend to listen to
you until I can get in your pants
because I'm sorry we did
the limes there let me help this out I
went to boarding school first time in
the United States 14 years old I'm in
boarding school I'm in Massachusetts
never live in the United States go to
the woods of Massachusetts I had a I
didn't know how to put an address on the
envelope yeah I was so [ __ ] weird and
I was such a foreigner that but I'll
give you an example so so my parents
were still in Saudi Arabia now I grown
up in the Middle East for eight years of
my life that was mainly right so in the
Middle East when your friends you hold
hands give me your hand when you go
there as your buddy you hold hands like
this or you lock fingers like seems
normal not considered gay it's just
considered what guys do right America
yep so we're gonna go to soccer I'm in a
dorm I'm in the United States I'm around
All American for any sports in across
seas I just really just judo didn't have
sports they didn't have organized sports
you Dead Sea play crypto some yeah
there's just pee I played baseball
playing baseball played some baseball so
um so I my friend Emmanuel he was my
roommate and as we went to go to you
know soccer I I put my I grabbed if you
just walk in he's grabbed his hand
because he's my new friend and then I'm
sorry I was like that's weird
so then I make my arm around the small
of his waist I'll never forget this he
goes we don't do that here I was like
sorry whatever I guess you don't [ __ ]
either either I guess
guess I'm not gonna get like to win some
games I'm homesick I can't bang you and
that was yeah that was and then that was
boarding school and then in the summers
I come back to which i go to i go to
summer camp in Wolfeboro Massachusetts
you don't like to Hampshire you're I
just you just moved around when I would
say when I was 33 years old I believe
his 33 was the first time I put a
painting or anything on a wall that's
how I lived man so so that does [ __ ]
whoever talk to a real therapist about
it yeah I did the same thing out of it
some guys do some no I didn't man I'm
sure I would but what what so okay so
ready so so I have a problem with
stability I have a problem you know so
so what happens you want people to like
you right away cuz you don't wanna be
lonely so you're in a new place
comic what a surprise what a surprise
that I now make a living staying in
front of strangers and going I'm gonna
make you laugh who's not same [ __ ] the
actors are the other you're playing
somebody else same she's saying and I
and I don't have time so I just let you
rock the psoriasis and all huh yeah I
got well they they paint my psoriasis
down and then I got I got my tube socks
I got my thighs y'all got the tight
shorts just the Reebok dad shoes I got
the real loser in it so you'd be
surprised I'm wearing the easy dad shoes
he's really similar huh
oh my god it's the generation that's it
those are dog leashes I've ever seen
that you're wearing right now de
terrible yeah they're the worst super
comfortable I know these are hot - man
yeah man the dad shoes the dad looks in
that dad looks that's the whole getup
huh yeah this is all good anyone say
anything when you walked in I'll wear
this show this show goes 10 years I wear
this show that's what that's what I wear
shorts you don't did this is it I better
get used to this and in the wintertime
when you're in the studio's and it's you
know it's 50 degrees you're in this it's
not fun especially the morning time is
that a UH was this oh we go watch uh yep
you know what you know what dude it's a
Seiko good job this is this is what
people wore in the eighties and nineties
well that's right yeah it's cool man
thanks bro
so got a little makeup on my face see
you let me give me smooth skin it got
good skin I'll leave it on though that's
right had to do a lot of my own stunts
today like dunk a basketball off jump
off a pad and then don't get there was
some stuff going on yeah it's been going
good it's been going good a lot of work
a lot of repetition you know how acting
is my friend okay no short days no short
days and how many weeks would you guys
shoot we got 13 episodes Brennan
so three weeks on one week off and so
one episode one week that's correct sir
that's quick now 30 sometimes you get a
director sometimes you get a DP a
director or a photographer photography
he wants to use his own lenses he's got
to change the lenses out things take
more time he wants the shot to look
beautiful that's gonna take that's gonna
take you into some some some late hours
sometimes dead a little annoying well
bet a little bit cuz you have your
trailer on there got my trailer boring
of those trailers there my trailer is a
modest trailer and there's not much to
do in that trailer there's a chair this
big mirror
there's a bathroom that's it couch craft
services this crowd I eat a lot of
crafty it's nice yeah they make me my
own coffee they're little things like
that